surviving a deadly disease
is in the blood here 350 years ago
a tailor in the village of eem ordered
some cloth from london
it was infested with fleas carrying the
plague
and the tailor was dead in days the
village
acted quickly to prevent the spread a
perimeter was put around the village and
this is one of the stones that marks the
boundary
nobody was allowed in and nobody was
allowed out
the village had put itself into lockdown
260 people died here but many more were
saved
i think there is something about in
people
that do does resonate that they've in a
small
isolated village there's a stoniness and
a resilience
here that i like to think maybe
fancifully
reflects back on 350 years ago the
people of em
have had to call on that resilience
again fighting coved like their
ancestors fought the great plague
but now it's time to open up again and
that has brought fear
and anticipation i personally think it's
a little bit premature
um but you know scientists know best so
you've got to trust
um what they're saying really you've got
to follow
the advice and keep your mask on
good morning surgery how can i help at
the village surgery they know an
increase in cases could mean busy times
are still ahead
gp dr ben milton has been leading the
vaccine rollout here
i think there's a real sense of
trepidation
and clearly that's tinged with some real
excitement we all want to get
back to something we recognize as a bit
more normal
but there's no doubt the the impact
certainly for us in general practice and
in healthcare widely
is going to be significant going
forwards over the next few weeks and
months still
this is the busiest time of the year for
villages like eem
the cool stone restaurant is getting
ready to welcome
more visitors we have to get back to
society
back to a way of living with covid it's
not going away
um and i think you know at the end of
the day it comes back to weighing up the
odds of
the pandemic versus society coping
within the pandemic
and so i think it has to be done
ultimately
and even amongst friends enjoying the
sunshine and the fresh air
there's a split in opinion i thought
when masks are no longer
compulsory if some people feel
uncomfortable with that they can't say
anything because they've no weight
behind that anymore
i wouldn't invalidate my friend's views
but i think yeah
massive mass panic for very little
really
350 years ago eem reopened after 14
months in isolation
the crisis was over today it's hoped the
same is true
nick martin sky news